can you tell me some of the experiments
that you've done take the audience
through a couple of the experiments so
one you amputate a frog's leg and then
you're able to regenerate it so on and
so on maybe outline three that you find
most flabbergasting
sure sure um okay uh let's see so so so
so here's one
if you use a voltage-sensitive
fluorescent dye which basically just
reports if you flood your your tissue
with it and it just reports
with with um different types of
fluorescence it reports where the
different voltage values are if you look
at the early embryo as it's putting its
face together for example you will see
something we call the electric face and
this was discovered in work with my
colleague danny adams where
we found this thing called the electric
face which is basically that prior to
all the genes being turned on that are
required to make different face
components and so on and certainly prior
to the anatomy there is a an electrical
pre pattern that you see in that region
that
basically looks like a face you can see
where the eyes are going to be because
that's where the voltage is different
you can see where the mouth is going to
be you can see where the placards on the
side of the head are going to be and so
you see this electrical face and it and
it raised the obvious uh the obvious
question which is that if that pattern
is instructive then you ought to be able
to do two things you ought to be able to
mess it up and thus disrupt that
electrical pattern and thus get defects
in craniofacial pattern against and
certainly you can do that and in fact
there are even human channelopathies
where humans have mutations and ion
channels that give them craniofacial
birth defects and defects of limb and
brain and other things so that
that so that's that's true but the other
thing the more exciting thing you might
be able to do
is to take some of those electrical
patterns and move them somewhere else
and you could say okay if if this is the
type of pattern that says to the cells
build an eye here
could we move that electrical state to
somewhere else not move the cells but
move the electrical pattern
reintroduce that electrical pattern
somewhere else and and get it to build
an iron so this is actually we we did
this this is some of our some of our
earlier work um you know around uh 2007
or so we we discovered this uh basically
you take one ion channel that's able to
induce a particular electrical pattern
in in the in a region of cells and you
inject rna encoding that ion channel in
some other part of the embryo that's
going to be gut let's say okay it's
going to make endoderms to make gut
cells and sure enough uh and so and so
three things are significant about what
happens the first is that you get an i
then you get an i in the middle of the
gut you get an eye constructed from
cells that were going to be gut
so this is remarkable because if you
look at the um
uh uh developmental biology textbooks
what you will see is that they say that
cells outside of the anterior neureterm
are not competent to become eyes they're
not supposed to be able to make eyes and
that's true if you use the the
biochemical master eye gene pac-6 if you
if you try to re-induce eyes with pac-6
that's true it doesn't form any you
can't get ectopic eyes anywhere outside
the head but by introducing this
bioelectric pattern you can and so
that's so that's the first thing that
you you can you can
go beyond the known uh competency limits
by using this very upstream sort of
master regulator this this electrical
pattern the second thing that's
interesting about it is that
the information content that we provide
by putting in this channel is extremely
low we don't micro specify the details
of how to make an eye you know i has a
dozen cell types all arranged in a
particular way we don't know how to do
that we couldn't possibly do you know we
couldn't possibly do that in fact
what what we do instead is provide a
very simple signal that to a programmer
basically looks like a subroutine call
right it's a trigger it's a trigger for
a cascade that the animal already knows
how to do it already knows how to make
eyes we're not saying how to make an eye
what we're saying is
make an eye here
by triggering that that eye building
module which includes all the gene
expression everything else that's
downstream so that modularity that that
that incredible um engineering trick
that uh that that says that you can call
up once you know how to do something you
can reuse it
in other places the fact that these
bioelectrical states are triggers of
developmental subroutines okay so that's
that's kind of the second cool thing
about it the third cool thing about it
is that if you label the cells that you
are injecting the channel rna into with
some with us with a color so you can so
you can tell which cells actually got
the
the extra channel and then you and then
you look at that eye that you've created
what you will see is that often for
example half the eye
will have the channel you put in the
other half the eye doesn't have it that
means that what the cells that you
affected what they did was they
recruited their normal neighbors
right which by themselves were never
modified by you they were completely
wild-type and
and yet they got recruited by their
neighbors to be part of this thing so
there's two levels of instruction here
there's instruction by us saying to a
region you make an eye and then there's
a secondary instruction by those cells
that say oh and by the way i'm going to
need more cells hey you guys over here
you're going to be part of this lens and
they all come and they even the ones
that we never directly affected and so
this third part is cool because
well the the the second part is cool the
the fact that it's it's modular and a
trigger is cool because that means that
you can
achieve regenerative medicine outcomes
things that are way too complex for us
to micromanage by using triggers if we
can identify
the triggers of the subroutines that we
want make an eye make a layer make a
liver
then we can trigger those things long
before we actually know all the details
about how to micromanage it right so
part of part of reverse engineering and
i very much see this as a reverse
engineering task part of reverse
engineering is finding out all the cool
hooks in the system that are already
there for you not that you have to put
them together from scratch but they're
already there for you yeah what is the
trigger that that's the build and i sub
routine what other subroutines are there
right that's that's that's part of our
job the other the thing that's cool
about that third part is that it's
non-cell autonomous meaning
you can exert effects on cells without
touching them directly because cells
communicate to each other so by
convincing a bunch of cells over here
that they should make an eye you in
effect uh affect a bunch of other cells
and cause them to be part of that eye
without having to touch them directly
and that comes up
sorry that's what you mean when you were
talking about recruiting earlier exactly
exactly right exactly right yeah so
that's so that's kind of the first
that's the first example um that that i
would i would talk about the second
example i would talk about uh has to do
with has to do with cancer and so
michael is it okay if we hold on that
cancer result because what you said was
so profound and i want to unpack it okay
sure sure yeah we'll hold on tell me if
this is broadly correct let's imagine
i'm a frog where the frog is developing
before an eye or a stomach or a throat
or whatever it is is made you see some
adabration some adam bration some
electrical atomization like a hint of it
and then what you could do is you can
say well there's some pattern let's
imagine it's a circle to be simplistic
there's some circular voltage gradient
and that means i so what if i induce
that what if i induce a voltage gradient
over here near the heart i know you said
something but whatever over here then
what will happen
is instead ordinarily we would think
well you need to micro tune that eye
each molecule it's extremely difficult
to make an eye we don't actually know
how to from the bottom up molecularly
make an eye but we see this pattern what
if we put that pattern on the heart or
the stomach oh lo and behold some time
amount later then an eye is born is that
correct
yeah that's that that's that's correct
and the only thing i would add to that
first of all is that the reason i was i
was telling you about that electric face
pattern is because it's kind of the most
obvious one in the sense that the
electric face pattern actually looks
like a face you can't miss it it just it
just looks like a face but not all of
them are that simple some of them are
really um
kind of uh um
they're encoded more deeply such that by
by staring at it you can't tell what
it's gonna be right so so for example uh
there are there are other patterns that
we've seen where the only way we know
what they are is is by watching what
they make we you couldn't have guessed
you know so some some of them are very
direct almost a paint by numbers you can
sort of see what's going to happen and
others are really complicated and you
need uh computational tools to
deconvolve what you're looking at to
figure out what it's going to be so so
not all of them are as obvious as the
electric face pattern right yeah one of
the questions i had was why hasn't this
been found out before was there a
technological limit or did they just not
look at cells with the dye that give an
indication of voltage gradients or
optogenetic technologies and so on yeah
so so that so
so that's an interesting question why
why why not before i mean on the one
hand everything has to have a beginning
at some point right so so whenever it
was it would have you know you could
have asked well like why not before
right but hindsight is always obvious
you can always you can always say but
but let's but let's kind of dig into
that um
on the one hand there was a conceptual
uh
leap that kept this pretty much under i
mean let's be clear i am not the first
person to talk about the importance of
bioelectric signals people have been
studying endogenous by electricity since
before 1900 so so it certainly has
occurred to people that maybe electrical
signals are important in development
regeneration all of my work i was i was
incredibly um heavily inspired
by by work that was done in this in the
60s 70s and 80s by a bunch of people
that worked really hard on this stuff
the reason that it hadn't gone far
enough was to two reasons number one
the tools weren't there so these dyes
didn't exist all they had was
traditional electrophysiology in
traditional electrophysiology you have
one electrode and you're poking it into
cells and if you want to have a picture
of what's going on you got to poke all
the cells and that's just completely
impractical right these dyes didn't
exist the conceptual thing was that
um around the time that this stuff was
was taking off using using electrodes
and things like that uh biochemistry and
molecular biology took off and the thing
the reason molecular biology drew all
the attention is because you could do
molecular biology and biochemistry in
dead fixed tissue
so you can you can kill and fix your
cells and you can sequence the dna you
can sequence the rna you can get a
proteome you can get a uh you know all
of these all of these kinds of things
you can do
none of that is possible with
bioelectrics so the minute your cell is
dead all of it goes away
so none of the typical olmics approaches
work so it's it's it's uh it's it's that
much harder and so it really lagged
behind because all the interest went
into the molecular uh you know kind of
molecular biochemistry and uh and it had
to wait for some of these tools to to
come up the third thing the third thing
is is that
i think
while
while people did uh
think about the importance of these
bioelectric gradients
nobody to my knowledge uh
before we did it really thought about it
as
the beginnings of the nervous system and
to really put that computational spin on
it the fact that this thing really is
liking neural network doing computations
about development i i think that's new i
will say um harold burr who was this guy
was working in the 30s 1930s 40s and 50s
okay he had one of the first good volt
meters around and he went around
measuring things you know elm trees and
rabbits and tumors and embryos and all
kinds of stuff on the basis of this he
wrote an amazing book um
that basically said most of the things
that we're discovering now the guy had a
crystal ball it's incredible it's
absolutely incredible so he he could
clearly see a lot of this stuff the
thing the the one thing he did not see
because at the time it didn't exist was
the computational aspect and the and the
really the link to um you know to to to
this as as a kind of neuroscience done
in another space in amorphous space that
i think is is new but but uh
people had already had these ideas and
it needed the technology to really make
it to really prove them out and to
really see how it works